we are all were dealing with a world
that is called international and we hear
words like internationalization oh
that's a good one a globalization
interdependence and my problem for a
long time has been this is at the
beginning of the chakras de Paume the
Charterhouse of Parma Sten dolls novel
we have the hero del dango for a priest
del dango and he's in the middle of the
battlefield at Waterloo and oh my
goodness of smoke and fog of war the
bullets are flying Napoleon is charging
back and forth on his horse and del
dango looks at this and he thinks to
himself you know something very
important is happening here I wish I
knew what it was
that's it interdependence there I am so
what I thought I'd try to work through
in the next few minutes or so is what
does it mean practically what is this
mean practically for I'm afraid lawyers
and judges but lawyers and judges affect
others too so it's people in a lot of
professional disciplines and I want to
say we all know this that there are two
tendencies at work and they're
considered great forces in the world
that's fair enough you have on the one
hand of the forces of internationalism
interdependence globalism those words
that are so big in general and then on
the other hand we have the local the
regional tribal even and very often when
we read in the newspapers or I do and
you do they look as they are clashing
they're at work there are these two
forces at work and
brexit you know brexit doesn't happen
every day but there are a lot of things
that happen that make us think that they
are forces that are at least in tension
if not in actual conflict so I want to
say for some of us professionals at
least most of the time forget the
conflict don't look at it that way we
live in a world where those are Givens
they aren't necessarily in conflict for
our ordinary work we have to deal with
both and we doomed and we don't even
consider them necessarily in conflict we
simply have a challenge which is v which
is shaped by those two forces and we
deal with that challenge know what am I
talking about usually I leave I asked
that first in my audience won't all ask
if that's a I'm a local judge I am a
local judge I am NOT an international
judge I deal with this document this is
the constitution of the United States we
deal with an American Constitution we
deal with American statutes American
administrative action but what I find
more and more is to do my job to do this
American job with American documents
with American laws I have to look beyond
our shores and that's really what I want
to show you law after all is not a
science it's at least in part a humane
discipline it isn't architecture it
isn't jazz but like them it does embody
an ancient universal human need
expressed in the book of Deuteronomy a
good day to recall that justice justice
shall you pursue
law helps to organize the lives of human
beings in communities in ways that allow
them to obtain the benefits of living
together productively and in peace so it
isn't surprising that law to
faces factual circumstances of the kind
that other disciplines architecture it
may be jazz economics environmental
science lots of other things also face a
world in which the international
evermore affects our daily lives now
here you've all we had that for many
many years America hasn't not to the
same degree not to the same degree and
where we the local lawyers the local
judges have to take increased account of
what goes on beyond our shores how can
we should we like other professionals
take account of globalization while at
the same time maintaining the importance
of local ties
now my experience has been the number of
cases in our court we hear about 80 each
year the number of cases where you have
to face that question has grown
dramatically since I was appointed to
the court about 20 years ago a little
more
maybe then you know I went to Europe and
went to a conference and came back and I
said I learned so much they are really
useful and
actually was a professor from Finland
who was at NYU for the year he said name
one yeah okay I found one but but that
would be no problem at all now maybe 5%
of our cases used to call for that kind
of thing look out beyond America now
maybe it's 20 25 percent 15 but 20
certainly thank God and that is a big
change and what they do is they say look
look out beyond in different ways and
I'm not talking just about treaties I
mean of course treaties do but things
that aren't treaties at all the
interpretation of our own domestic
constitution our own statutes our own
laws and
when I speak to an American audience
about this I'm absolutely certain to get
this some form of this but this is an
American Constitution isn't it this is
an American Constitution why are you
looking elsewhere and I say well I my
opinion and I need a I need what I have
your 40 minutes or 30 minutes more to
convince you that the best way to
preserve our American values is to look
beyond our shores
you